the last place of Refuge for pushbarai
and her family they've moved to the
Terrace with Bare Essentials and are
hoping to camp out until flood waters
that have partially submerged their
house recede
they is a power cut and we are facing a
shortage of drinking water and food we
are living on the Terrace and are also
cooking here we have not got help from
anyone
many others are less fortunate they were
evacuated from their homes and moved to
a temporary shelter under a busy fly
over after their settlements were washed
away by an overflowing river
when it was supposed to flood at 5 PM we
got to know only at 10 A.M that morning
we scrambled to save our things some
managed to get their belongings to
safety others could not
the relief camps have little to offer
with no food drinking water or toilets
leaving many disappointed with the
government Arrangements
there are a lot of issues there are few
toilets newborns and their mothers are
facing problems because they're not able
to eat breakfast and breastfeed people
want dry rations the yamna river that
flows through the capital normally Rises
during the monsoon season but this year
it's at a 45-year high environmentalists
say the flash flood disaster is man-made
with floodplains of the river being
compromised by Decades of construction
projects law of construction that has
happened in and around yamuna is that
the cost of the river are Town planners
never took into account a weather event
of this magnitude and in fact imagine if
you look at ipcc report several of the
reports that have actually come they
clearly warned us of extreme weather
events and extreme weather events is
just not in knowledge it also means
preparation and that preparation
completely failed the failure is clear
to see with several important roads and
bridges submerged disrupting the lives
of millions even the historic Red Fort
has been affected
River levels in the yamuna are expected
to fall with a force closure of three
water treatment plants could lead to
shortages of drinking water
um Sharif Al Jazeera